Elon tweeted this this is just great
this is the CBC Canadian broadcasting
corporation's official Twitter account
it has now been labeled labeled 69
government-funded media and you might be
watching that looking at that going 69
69 is a funny number why why'd that
happen uh as Elon said Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation said they're
quote less than 70 percent government
funded so we corrected the label the guy
is not only doing the right thing
calling out government and corporate
sponsored media where it should be
called out he's also having fun doing it
and there was a time guys
for those of you that are of a certain
age there was a time when the internet
was a fun place and the guys ushering
that back in and that's how we'll win
through memes and humor and all of those
things so now the CBC is labeled State
propaganda in essence right NPR will not
tweet the New York Times doesn't have a
blue check suddenly the old structures
what are we always talking about here
these old institutions that are
crumbling and lying to us instead of
strengthening them by giving them
attention and dollars and everything
else he's actually taking their power
away you know who's upset about that
well you've got Justin Trudeau up in
Canada Justin Trudeau is just he's like
the worst of the worst he's basically
Gavin Newsom light and here he is
whining about what that mean mean Mr
Elon Musk did
I think it says a lot about the
Conservative Party of Canada
they're choosing to constantly attack
Independent Media organizations
journalists who are working hard to keep
Canadians informed and support our
democracies
CBC Radio Canada
serves right across the country
delivers local news and local content in
many regions of the country
that in order to attack this institution
that is important for many many
Canadians
he runs to American billionaires
the tech Giants that they continue to
defend in committee
and in their uh in their approach on our
legislation to make Tech Giants pay
their fair share conservatives are
always there to defend them so when
they're trying to attack a foundational
Canadian Institution
fact that he has to run to American
billionaires
for support to attack Canadians
all right there's so much there so first
off uh he starts by attacking the
Conservative Party of Canada which is
not in power right the Liberals are in
power he's in power despite the fact
that he got something like 33 of the
vote now the conservatives in Canada
might be annoyed by all of this why
would they be annoyed by the uh CBC well
they might be annoyed by the CBC because
it basically just like our New York
Times and MSNBC and corporate press here
is in bed with the Dems the CBC is in
bed with the Liberals go try to find a
positive article about the conservatives
on the CBC or go try to find a positive
article about the Libertarians which is
the Freedom Party of Canada that was my
friend Maxine bernier's party uh try to
find something that the CBC says nice
about them no they do everything in
coordination with his party so he's very
upset that the conservatives those mean
conservatives and then that billionaire
in America would be pushing back against
his propaganda machine because the left
can't win without a propaganda machine
[Music]
thank you